i'm trying to keep me
all right victoria victoria where you
from originally where'd you grow up
um i was born in las vegas
but when i was nine i left
and went to arkansas and my my mom moved
out there
and i lived back and forth between vegas
and arkansas
between your mom and dad yeah yeah and
how was your childhood
um i come from a russian household
so russians tend to be really violent
and there's a lot of physical abuse
a little bit of sexual abuse
my one some memories i have is
my uh when i was about 13 my uncle shot
at me
and when i was about 16 my mom
fractured my face with a pipe when she
was drunk
it sounds pretty rough yeah just stuff
like that you know
what kind of kid were you in high school
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh i got into the punk rock scene pretty
early
so uh my grades were not good
um by the time i was in high school i
was already shooting heroin
and living on the streets
so they would send me home because my
clothes would be too ripped up
so i just stopped going how far did you
go in high school
sophomores i got my ged
later okay and then where'd you go from
there
um you're living on the street i
continued to
live on the street and then when i was
18 i was arrested
on a big drug bust i got raided
and uh i did some time in jail
and i got out and i went to rehab the
first time
and um
i i had a person in there that i met
i was always been an artist and she saw
some of my stuff
and she gave me a tattoo kit
and when i was 18 i started a tattoo
apprenticeship
and i became a tattoo artist after two
years professionally
and this was where this was in l.a now
you know so now you're in l.a yeah how'd
you end up down here on skid row that's
kind of fuzzy
um i think i used to have a dealer
that was more in echo park but
i lost touch with him so
i knew you could come down here and just
ask people for drugs and they would sell
them to you
so i pretty much just did that
how did you first get introduced to
heroin
i was being physically abused by my
father
he would choke me and he'd shot steroids
and he'd choke me and climb on top of me
and just do weird [ __ ] and um
i i one day was
in front of a smoke store and i was
underage i was like 16
and i uh was trying to get someone to
buy me a pack of smokes
and this kid did he came back out and he
said do you do black
and i just said [ __ ] it in my head and i
said yeah
so he took me to his apartment and he
shot me up
with tar and i overdosed so he then he
shot me up with cocaine
to bring me out of it because this was
before narcan was around
what are you doing for money now right
now i'm bouncing around
um there was a period a very short
period of time that
i sold my body
but i just couldn't do it it wasn't in
me
but boosting mainly
so how much how much will you make a day
boosting um
it just depends you know depends on the
security guards and what's going on
you've been arrested before about 15
times
oh really
lots of those how long did they hold you
for
not long i always got a word
like lit out on my own recognizance
so looking at the situation you're in
now heroin addict
is it just heroin or what are you using
now um fentanyl
heroin um
[Music]
benzos and
sometimes like if people if i'm in like
a tent and people are like either
smoking speed or crack
and they pass it to me i'll hit it but
i'm not
i can do without it i don't really i'm
not addicted to it
but look looking at your situation today
where you're using drugs living on the
street
do you make a connection with your uh
the childhood you had
the family you grew up in
you know i really don't know because
you know i went to aaa for a very long
time
and they kind of tell you that like
you know you were born with this disease
of addiction
and but i think it's a mixture of both i
think it's
hereditary and and your
upbringing mixed together yep i think
that makes sense
you get depressed sometimes all the time
yeah it's a rough life yeah
do you have any friends
friends on the street or like real real
friends
both both good for you but uh i have a
couple
i have two guys that are sober
like they have a couple years sober
in aaa and they've always looked out for
me
and made any time i want to get sober
they help me
that's great how many years you've been
here on the street that's a good run
huh how long have you been here on skid
row oh off and on for 10 years
i hold you 29 you're 29.
yeah i try not to like i like i don't
have a tent down here on my own
because i don't want to get stuck down
here you know
like i don't want this to become my life
i i want to be a mural artist and travel
the world and do murals and
and continue with my tattoo or
i'm also a graffiti artist so
what's what's the the worst thing you've
seen since you've been down here
for a decade
either to you or someone else
let me think about that because there's
some hot
i've seen a lot um
[Music]
oh i know what it is oh what is it
um i was sleeping in the l.a river
one night and it was thanksgiving
morning
i woke up this guy woke me up and
i can't disclose to you where it is just
because of the nature of the
incident but
he asked if i did black i said yeah
and he said i sell so i was like okay
you want to sell me some black and
he said yeah yeah just follow me down to
my spot he's like
he was like um also my family's doing
thanksgiving
uh dinner morning like a morning thing
for thanksgiving
and he's like you can come eat with us
if you want
he seemed very sincere and nice and then
we had to cross the river and it was
we were all stuck in the bushes and
nobody could see
us and he grabbed me and he pulled his
pants down
and he started pushing my head down
and grabbed my arm so i couldn't fight
back
and i said i had a blade up my sleeve i
said don't do this don't do this
and i was like seriously i'm warning you
don't do this
and he's like no no come on just a
little and i'm like dude please do not
do this
and he's like no no come on and he kept
pushing me
so finally i was like okay i'll do it
and he let his grip loose a little bit
and i slid the blade out of my hand and
i stabbed him in the neck
and i had blood up to my elbows and
everywhere
and and i then i just ran
and i i ran until i started puking
and i couldn't stop puking and then
i found a gas station and i put my arms
in my
shirt and i went in the bathroom and
washed all the blood off
wow
you know what happened to him huh do you
know what happened to him
i don't care either
i mean i do understand that most people
who
are rapists do it because they were
probably raped as a child
so it does make me feel sad for him
because of that fact
but you know i was you know
beaten as a child i had child abuse and
i don't do that to other people
you know but what's the most important
lesson you've learned
in your time on the street
respect if you respect people
they'll typically respect you back but
sometimes especially
you know the mess down here um
when the men smoke the mess down here
they get really horny and
all their inhibitions go right out the
window
so um
do you want me to tell you that story
about yesterday
so um this guy
i know from around you know i don't know
super well but i know
i know if i'm around and he
i was tired i was up all night and i saw
i ran into him
and he's like oh you look tired and i
was like yeah
and he's like well i gotta run some
errands but you can go
crash at the tent for a couple hours if
you need to
you know just get rejuvenated
and uh so he did
and i woke up and he was on top of me
and he pulled my pants down and spread
my legs and
he pulled his pants down and he was
trying to force himself in me
and i got a hold of a wire over here
and i wrapped around his neck and pulled
it
and then he kind of started to pass out
so i kind of got him off me a little and
i took his knife
which i still have and i said this
you have two options right now you can
either get off of me or i can [ __ ]
stick you
so i i mean and don't get me wrong i
have been raped
i haven't gotten out of it every time
but
you know it's good i think it sends a
good message to women
to say that you can fight back you don't
have to just let it happen
you can fight back
excellent well victoria thank you so
much for talking with me and uh
good luck out there stay safe thank you
i'll try you know you know um
hoover he he seems like a legit guy
like i stayed the night with him last
night he didn't even talk about sex not
even one time
he did it yeah he didn't
he wasn't trying to get you know nothing
out of it